this is major Roy McBride I'm attempting  to reach dr. Clifford McBride  this is dr. McBride Sonia  dad I'd like to see Union  [Music]  I've recall how we used to watch  black/white movies together musicals  were your favorite I remember you  tutoring me in math he instilled in me a  strong work ethic you should know I've  chosen a career that you would approve  of I've dedicated my life to the  exploration of space I thank you for  that  [Music]  what is happening out there is a crisis  of unknown magnitude  [Music]  we believe your father may be involved  my father's dead what exactly are you  implying for me  exploration is low is a noble venture  we have to hold out the possibility that  your father may be hiding from us  we have a job to do are you ready I'm  ready  [Music]  you  [Music]  you